olivia are you ready to
press live yeah we're now live
yes thank you anne
uh so welcome to this meeting of cabinet
and i'd like to give an a special
welcome to matt jennings who's joined
cabinet
and we're all looking forward to his
contribution so
formally welcome matt um
when i look at the agenda today there is
one
item uh on the agenda
which is uh
part c recommendations from policies and
practice task
and finish group i have to say this is a
very substantial
and significant paper and needs careful
consideration
before being discussed by cabinet could
i also
make a request please that where there
are
papers that are this substantial and
significant
they really do know clearly flagging in
the agenda
um this one i have to say
i had not fully realized it was coming
because it's in small print
and i really do think we need greater
clarity on when there is something as
significant as this paper coming so
that's just a comment from me uh
other than that everything else on the
agenda stays
so without further ado
we move on and apologies for absence and
should we do a raw calls for attendance
of counsellors
yeah yeah okay so if we start
um with yourself council jefferson i'm
assuming you can see and hear
everything okay i can see in here
excellent thank you councillor pemberton
thank you and yes i confirm that i can
see and hear
all of the proceedings and i have the
papers in front of me
thank you councillor barker yes
councillor cargill yes i'm okay
come to harvey yes can see here and have
the papers thank you
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings i can hear and see all
proceedings
thank you councillor parry
thank you i can see here the proceedings
and i have the papers in front of me
thank you and
thank you councillor shenter i can
confirm i have the papers and that i can
hear and see everything
thank you councillor wardy hoggins
uh this is council wally hoggins
confirming that i can see and hear
everything and that i have some papers
in front of me thank you
thank you and there are no apologies
chairman
thank you and so moving on then
disclosures of interest are there any
disclosures of interest please
i'll take that as a no so moving
on minutes uh
just one thing i want to raise on the
minutes
uh in terms of the landscape master plan
for the recreation ground
uh we now have a meeting with the sports
club arranged for
later this month and a more
comprehensive paper
will be produced for future
consideration
i have to just also report that work is
underway
as referred to in the minutes under
one two three so
with that i've got no further comments
on the minutes does anybody else have
any comments on the minutes
counselor june edge has asked if you
could raise a question
fine councillor junior yes could i just
ask on minute
128 the local industrial and economic
development strategy action plan
it's down as has been being prepared for
winter 2020
2021 can i be assured that that is still
on track
uh council of pemberton do you wish to
respond to this
yes uh leader i can confirm that uh
uh we are still on track with that and
the policy team uh
have work underway already so
uh yes i i have no reason to believe
that that position has changed at all
since the last
meeting are you satisfied counselor
junior
uh yes um i i was i'm satisfied
i also wanted to raise uh with
councillor jennings at some point
uh a follow-on question but i'll leave
it to later
thank you so with that then are the
minutes uh
accepted
do i need the proposal and the second
please on
and you can take a proposal in a second
but by and large if there's nobody
that's got anything further to say
we can take it as minutes has been
agreed in that case we take the minute
has been agreed thank you anne
uh moving on uh
deputy leader place bo desert and henley
in arden
ndp regulation 14 consultation
councillor pemberton
thank you leader um the bow desert and
henley in our arden neighborhood
development plan
is working its way through the process
that will ultimately lead
to um approval by the planning
inspectors
and a local referendum we've reached the
stage where
uh the main bulk of the work is done and
we're now at what's called regulation 14
the pre-submission consultation
and the the ndp has been considered by
our policy officers and uh the
recommendation is that the
schedule of significant comments at
appendix one be endorsed and submitted
to the boden henley in our joint parish
council
as the formal response to the
presupposition for the
pardon me the pre-submission
consultation process
and associated with the draft bow
dessert and henley in our
neighborhood development plan um so
it is there for the point at which we we
are making our comments then for the
ndp group for to take that back
and rework that up before final
submission uh at this point i'd just
like to thank our officers for the work
that they've put in
alongside the sterling work done by the
ndp group
in uh bird dessert in indiana to get us
to this point
uh unless there's any other questions
i'm i'm looking for a second or two
the recommendation thank you leader are
there any
points to raise members of council
members of cabinet
council uh parry and then councillor
harvey
thank you leader i just wanted to add my
my um comments to councillor pemberton i
just feel the depth and the detail to
which our offices has gone to and
responding
just shows how diligent our policy team
are um and i think it's very
comprehensive
and i'm i'm sure it'll be very very
helpful
going forward and on that basis i'd be
very happy to second the proposal
councillor harvey you indicated desire
to speak
a question um paragraph
5.1.2
read neighborhood plans must be
compatible
with eu obligations and human rights
requirements
could i be told when the requirement to
be consistent with
eu obligations is likely to fall away
thank you councillor harvey
specific eu regulations will fall away
um as we leave the transition period
uh which as i recall is 31st of december
um we will still have obligations on the
human rights act
which uh will will still uh which still
has the force of uk law it is a uk piece
of legislation
and unless or until that is amended um
that that will stay in place
uh that's it's really just a uh you know
a tidying exercise
to to reference the current legislative
process as it currently stands
thank you i think that's a very
interesting point to raise councillor
harvey that i
assume that uh all officers will be very
mindful
of when we actually do come to the end
of the transition period and that that
comment will actually
disappear from papers
so without further ado we have a
proposal in councillor
cargill thank you just a quick one
really
thank you the the plans themselves are
coming forward now but they can't go to
referendum
because we're not having a referendum
does that
because they're effectively being made
as regards planning policy
uh what happens with regards to the sill
um application because normally um
without a
neighborhood main neighborhood
development plan you get 15 percent of
any sole
income um the with a made plan is 25
is it still only on the 15 percent um
for plans like this that haven't been
made yet
interesting question councillor cargill
councillor pemberton
thank you leader thank you councillor
cargill
um i mean at a practical level this
ndp is not he's not ready for its
referendum
and clearly um
when it gets to that stage we'll have to
look at how we
run a referendum in light of where we're
at with the pandemic
i am not aware of any changes to the
sill regulations
um that would make
any change to the percentages on the
basis that referendums
cannot currently be held i will check i
will take further advice from our planet
planning policy team as to whether they
understand there to be any additional
uh updates or uh advice from central
government
but i wouldn't be holding your breath on
that
thank you councillor pemberton so we
have a proposal if there are no further
questions
uh i have a proposal in council of
pemberton
the secondary councillor parry so the
recommendation is on page nine
uh the recommendation is quite
straightforward so
can i have your agreement members of
cabinet to the recommendation on page
nine
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on
we move to capital budget monitoring
which is councillor harvey
councillor harvey you are muted
i'm worth waiting for
the apologies of this paper is to keep
members informed of the progress made
over the first four months of the year
in undertaking the council's intended
level of capital expenditure this year
table 1 on page 25
demonstrates the intention to undertake
expenditure of 10.7 million pounds this
year
including section 106 projects
taking into account additional funds of
2.9 million pounds budgeted for this
year
this will result in the balance of the
council's accumulated capital receipts
and grants
being reduced over the year assuming all
capital projects
budgeted were to be delivered from 6.4
million pounds to an overspend
of 1.4 million pounds paragraph 1.5
indicates that capital expenditure of
1.1 million pounds
has already been undertaken by the end
of july
in the first four months of the year
therefore the sums
spent or committed amount to 10
of this year's available budget of 10.7
million
appendix 2 on pages 35
to 37 provides summary information
concerning the various yet to be funded
projects
through section 106 agreements
i'd like again to draw attention to a
single element
that is the degree to which the amount
of funds
allocated under section 106 agreements
relates to affordable housing
at this time last year the amount of
section 106
funds allocated to affordable housing
was 1.7 million
at the end of july this year that amount
has more than
doubled to 3.5 million
the potential impact the district
council can possibly have
uh can possibly having saving itself on
the provision of sorting
of affordable housing over needs to be
seen
in perspective the district has
approximately
56 000 residences upon which it levies
council tax with an average
build cost per affordable unit of
166 000 pounds
the council's financial capacity to
provide affordable housing
from this source has increased in the
past year
from 10 units to 21 units
despite this relatively modest level of
potential
it's still important that sdc makes its
contributions to the district's housing
stock
i like every other member of the cabinet
i'm looking forward to considering our
policy in this area
through the housing investment panel in
the coming weeks
i asked therefore leader that the
current position
on capital expenditure and income for
the period to the end of july
2020 is noted
thank you councillor harvey before i ask
members of cabinet if there's any
uh issues they wish to raise or debate
i believe we have a public speaker
and or a member of the public wishing to
speak rather
we do they are just dialing in at this
moment in time
[Music]
um in fact they've just arrived in the
lobby so if you just give us a couple of
seconds and we'll call them in
speakers in now anne thank you hello
hello
okay if you can hear me jenny could you
press
star 6 to unmute please
hello hello ah
is that jenny it is yes okay
um you're um you've been called by the
leader so your time
to start speaking is in a few seconds is
that all right
yes that's fine thank you lovely okay
you can go ahead thank you
hello my name is jenny loins and i'd
like to ask a question of the cabinet on
behalf of
stratford climate action my question is
as follows to meet the target of net
zero greenhouse gas emissions
by 2020 to 2030 friends of the earth
recommends a target of 20
tree coverage across the whole
stratford-on-avon district
achieving this over the next 10 years
will require planting of circa
1.6 million trees every year this year's
tree planting season starts in november
can the council confirm that they have
put in place the necessary
2020 2021 capital expenditure budget
to sort the required volume of trees
manpower and suitable land
and have undertaken the required
environmental impact assessments to make
sure we meet this challenge
for the 2020 2021 tree planting season
thank you thank you
um just a very quick response from me
at the moment we
our budget is in a considerable state of
flux
uh we do not know as yet exactly what
the details are from the third funding
round
from government we do not know what the
financial settlement would be
so until we have clarity on those
i don't think we're in any position to
allocate
sums of money however
should greater clarity emerge we may
well be able to catch up in future years
okay there's a few people that would
like
um to ask a question
are they entitled to um yes they can't
so
um i think counselor tune ed would like
to follow up on the question
members of cabinet yes sorry yeah fine
councillor junior yes um following up on
that one
um one thing that i have been pressing
for and i would like to have assurance
on
is that the climate panel will be um
put in place and that we will have a
firm date um
for that to take on board the tasks the
recommendations that came from the task
and finished group
i would uh i'd like you to um you know
make sure that
we do have a date certainly by the the
full council day
thank you i will make sure a meeting is
arranged councillor junior
uh as you are well aware a we've been
suffering from the
culvert 19 and b life has been a little
frantic
but now the holiday season is over we'll
get it organized
right any more questions on
councillor barker
councillor barker yeah i just wanted to
make a comment
um without being facetious my quidda
tree scheme
seems to be something that we perhaps
ought to be thinking about
uh bringing back where i suggested that
we could all contribute to this and we
could get our kids growing little trees
we don't have to have a huge amount of
land acquired we don't have to use
public land because we can plant trees
in gardens we can plant hedgerows
and we should all be taking
responsibility for this and it's
something that we
i think as local councillors
particularly can be
leading the charge on in difficult times
it is still
something that we can do um and
i would encourage um all our
to all the children and grandchildren
around us to be sent out to get acorns
and plant them up so we're ready for
with our oak forest for the next year
thank you thank you councillor barker i
think that's a good idea and i think
that should be one of the items
on the first meeting of the climate
change group
uh so we have councilor parry would like
to speak
leader councillor parry
and then councillor kettle
councillor parry and then councillor
kettle thank you leader sorry
problems on muting um just really a
comment
um in instead of giving other presents
for people's birthdays i've now started
to give
trees to people for their weddings
for their birthdays um and that
particular
gesture has gone down particularly well
what an excellent idea councillor parry
councillor kettle
have you been given a tree
well i have because i've got the two
councillor paris and council
yourself your own tree which we were
given last year which are
potted on and growing well as part of
the donation we received
to all councillors i think from either
friends of the earth or greenpeace i
can't quite run for whom with the kind
donors
um but they are thriving at the moment
um i'm gonna change tax slightly mr um
mr chairman if you don't mind
uh and go back to um affordable housing
contributions
and that these contributions arise
because developers are not building
affordable housing in the developments
they're actually putting together
which deprives those communities of
having
35 or whatever percentage may be
um of affordable housing adding to their
own
uh settlement housing stocks so as a
district it looks good
but for communities it does mean there
is a
effect not as so much as a shortfall but
actually people are missing out
and i think we just need to be careful
going forward
because the housing investment panel has
approved
an application recently and during the
height or the depth of the lockdown
um i was
down with the council to approve
a very last minute um application
for additional housing affordable
housing contribution from this council
to a scheme
now that's great but i think we need to
ensure
that when the money for this
pot is coming out of communities that we
need to ensure where possible
that that money goes back into the
communities particularly the more rural
communities
rather than being aggregated in the
centers of whether it be
uh stratford or the main rural centers
uh because actually the affordable
housing is as much needed in the rural
settlements
where it may be less convenient for
developers but affordable housing
than it is for the big centers
councillor kettle
i i understand the point you're making
but i think that
is more an issue in terms of affordable
housing
than it may well be in terms of capital
budget monitoring
but i take the point and
i think it's minuted and we'll be looked
at councillor harvey
you wish to comment i don't wish to
have a housing investment panel debate
um
here but i just make um
two points really one is in response to
council the kettle
the sources of this uh housing
affordable money affordable housing
money in section 106
currently uh according to the the
information in front of you
comes from 28 different parts of the
district
um so my point in mentioning the figures
of um we could have afforded to build
10 last year and up to 21 this year
these are very modest
numbers uh set against the need and
i think what i'm really pointing at is
that
section 106 money for affordable housing
doesn't lead to very much affordable
housing
the issue really ought to be wherever
possible
tackled at the planning stage and and
the
affordable housing allocation be
included
within the development that's the best
way in the most
productive way of us ensuring that we
provide affordable housing within the
district and it's
whatever we do with section 106 money is
going to be
small very small in relation to the
demand that's the only point i'd make
i think your point is extremely well
made councillor harvey
and i am very well aware that we do not
want to strain to having
a housing investment panel discussion
when we are looking at capital budget
monitoring
so with that in terms of capital budget
monitoring
members of cabinet are there any further
points to raise
councillor yeah councillor united and
council of pemberton have forced us to
speak
yes um it was exactly that point that i
was
uh wanted to raise uh and and council
harvey has put that
uh very well uh i wanted a little bit of
a a briefing
about how it would be spent uh and how
the housing investment panel will deal
with it
i note for example that nearly 800 000
of that
comes from um development in in the town
of ulster
where we do have a specific shortage of
affordable housing
so it's a question that i want to be
able to put on somebody's agenda
for more discussion about how we make
sure we get the affordable housing i've
been dealing with
considerable case work of people who
want affordable housing within that
within this area
and i would like to be able to show
assure them that that could be done
i think this is probably a matter for
the housing investment panel
so with that members of cabinet are we
happy with the recommendation on page
25.
so can i have a proposal and a second to
please
counselor harvey councillor barker
our members of cabinet in agreement with
it
i'll take that as a unanimous yes
thank you so moving on revenue budget
monitoring once again councillor harvey
thank you leader the purpose of this
report is to inform the cabinet
of the revenue picture of the council's
finances
to the end of july 2020. uh
i'd like to begin by asking members to
turn to appendix
3 on page uh i think it's 71 but
that could be could be different it's
appendix 3.
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year
is now 17 million pounds in round
numbers if we now turn to appendix
2 on page 47 we can see that the budget
for the whole year
is for total expenditure of 28.1 million
pounds
and total income from various sources of
11.4 million pounds
the difference between these two numbers
28.1 and 11.4
is 16.6 million pounds together with the
net
cost of the benefits of 186 000 pounds
represents the total amount to be funded
from various sources
i.e it's 16.8 million pounds
as set out in appendix 2. in addition
appendix 2 also sets out that as a
result of the kovid 19 pandemic
the council has received civil
contingencies funding
from the government of 33.9 million
pounds
of which 37.2 million pounds has been
distributed
in ways consistent with the government's
intentions
leaving a balance of 3.3 million pounds
at the end of july turning to the
position at the end of period
4 we can see that in rounded terms
the council's expenditure of 15.3
million pounds
was three million pounds less than
budgeted
this reflects a variety of decisions to
avoid and delay expenditure
in light of the current very challenging
and changed circumstances
the impact of the covid19 pandemic
is similarly illustrated in the
shortfall
against budgeted income to the end of
july of
4.3 million pounds principally due to
shortfalls in revenue of 2.4 million
pounds
generated from fees and charges
principally
738 000 pounds of revenue lost from the
district's car parks alone
the combination of these results means
that the net
cost of services provided in the first
four months of the year was two and a
half times
what was budgeted section three of the
paper identifies the principal items of
variance
from their budgeted figures during the
period april to july
whilst section four provides estimates
for the out turn for the year
in full managers and heads of service
are to be commended again in providing
these estimates
in the face of such continuing
uncertainty
section six of the paper demonstrated
demonstrates
the strain that the pandemic is having
on the council's
reserve position which at this stage
it's this stage is estimated will be
halved in total
by the end of the financial year
importantly
appendix 4 identifies the council's
current
earmarked reserves which are likely to
come
under close scrutiny in the coming weeks
and months the important element to the
council's finances for the remainder of
the current year
that remains to be determined is the
amount of funding
the government will make available under
tranche 3
of the covered 9 19 related
civil contingencies funding subject to
any further information that mr
hill might be in a position to provide
about the outcome of the tranche iii
considerations
and to any questions members may have i
ask
that the poor report be received
thank you councillor harvey i have
councillor june had wishing
to comment and councillor kettle wishing
to speak councillor junit
thank you and can i welcome councillor
jennings to the to the cabinet
uh what i want to ask is slightly uh
related to the
revenue budget that is actually within
his portfolio um
could i be reassured now that the
economic recovery working group that has
was talked about
will now be set up because several items
within the revenue
budget will be appropriate
i think if i could answer that one
counselor junior yes it will be set up
um i must admit i
thought that was underwear but i will
check on that and make sure it is
counselor kettle thank you mr chairman
uh just to say that
uh following receipt of cabinet papers i
did send quite a detailed memo
to mr hill copied to the councillor
harvey
um and mr hill sent me a very
comprehensive
explanation of um some further questions
which i raised
um uh from that email so i'd just like
to thank mr hill for
that uh and um i would commend mr
councillor harvey for his uh
comprehensive um
summary we've just heard but just to say
mr hill has given me considerable
further detail
my satisfaction thank you councillor
kettle
uh so um
the recommendation is on page 39
uh councillor harvey has proposed
the recommendation can i have a second
to please
ian councillor shenton the second day
can i have your approval members of
cabinet please thank you
i will take that as agreed
so uh moving on uh
part c issues arising from overview and
scrutiny i've already dealt with
part d cabinet committees that are non
on black eye on block items uh
these are approved on block unless a
request is made at the start of the
meeting for an item to be discussed
so they are the housing investment panel
minutes we have to receive and the
stratford upon even markets for them
minutes we have to receive uh
can i take it that we have received both
of those
uh minutes
thank you members of cabinet urgent
business
there is none so at 1603
i declare the meeting closed thank you
everyone for attending
bye bye bye